sexual misconduct scandals dominating
the headlines this week apologies by
senator Al Franken denials why Alabama
GOP Senate candidate Rory Moore here to
react to it all syndicated columnist and
host of the ben shapiro show Ben Shapiro
joins me now
thanks for being here tonight on just at
your first time Ben we're thrilled to
have you on all right Ben I want I want
to call for the sound of kirsten
gillibrand from new york when she's
being questioned by a New York Times
reporter wants to take a listen is it
your view that the President Clinton
should have stepped down at that time
given the allegations yes I think that
is the appropriate response don't you
think it's rather interesting that
within ten months where senator
Gillibrand from New York is like Hillary
Clinton is a role model for women we
love her she's great and she's gonna
drag along her hubby bill and then all
of a sudden yeah that guy should have he
should have resigned besides being a
hypocrite isn't she opportunistic and
should people feel comfortable with her
as a United States Senator I mean I'm
not sure they should feel comfortable
three as a United States Senator and in
any circumstances but certainly you know
that this this notion that Democrats
have suddenly decided that Bill Clinton
should have been impeached seven did you
know twenty years ago that this idea
we're gonna get in Doc Brown's time
machine and go back and get rid of
Clinton then but they were all they're
all giving him a standing ovation in the
Rose Garden when he was a paged and now
they're coming out and saying ten months
after he becomes politically useless to
them now they're gonna throw his corpse
under the bus and when they finally get
a chance to condemn somebody who's
actually sitting right now all right
senator Franken then all of a sudden
they say oh well you know we want we
don't want him to go what we'd really
like to send an ethics committee
investigation and for people who don't
know what a Senate Ethics Committee
investigation is the answer is it's
nothing it's a big nothing between 2007
2007 and 2016 there were something like
613 reports to the the Senate Ethics
Committee for investigation and there
were zero sanctions none so the idea I
mean Al Franken called for an
investigation of himself he said I'd
like a Senate Ethics investigation of me
yeah okay if you're guilty of stuff and
we know he's guilty there's a picture of
him trying to grab a lady's boobs on
investigate there if you know you're
guilty and you're calling for an
investigation that probably suggests
that the investigation doesn't mean a
whole helluva lot but but the whole
thing is when he apologized and people
say always so greedy apologizing Hillary
apologized she said you know as if she
should be telling women how they should
react in cases like this the truth is he
apologized for taking the picture he
didn't apologize for doing all the
things she accused him of doing and yet
didn't let that claims to be the
protectors and the guardians of women
are the party that never believed women
Hillary Clinton was part of the party
that trashed women I mean do we owe
women like Monica Lewinsky on whose
dress these semen was found of the
President of the United States talk
about an imbalance of power between a
president and an aunt and in turn two we
owe her an apology
do we all Juanita Broderick an apology
who made an immediate outcry regarding a
rape to a minimum of five women that's
exactly right ma'am if you look at the
wanita broderick story particularly last
year President Trump during the campaign
brought up Roderick and the media said
it was completely inappropriate for him
to do so how dare he bring up Juanita
Broderick now we have op-eds in the New
York Times about how Democrats suddenly
believe the Juanita Broderick which says
to me that this is much more an issue of
political convenience for Democrats than
it is about any sort of principle that
they're trying to uphold suddenly
they've become conservatives you know
typical kind of traditionalist
conservatives when it comes to sexual
misconduct except when it comes to their
own people of course they're they
maintain their old standard and you know
what's interesting it for years we have
been paying off the taxpayers you and me
for the sexual misdeeds of those in
Congress should Rory Franken be forced
to Al Franken be forced to resign yeah I
think Franken she got I think if you
before stories on I mean it doesn't seem
to me right now Alabama
what should happen to him I said that
more should be he should step down from
the race and I think that if he's
elected he should immediately be not
seated I mean I think that the
allegations against Roy Moore are
incredibly serious they seemed to me
very credible he's done almost nothing
to rebut any of the serious allegations
made against him and the idea that we
are going to be seating people with
credible allegations of child
molestation against them that haven't
been rebutted in any serious way
that doesn't make a lot of sense to me
on any level listen if we're gonna have
a country if we can have a social fabric
where we can actually trust each other
regardless of what side of the political
aisle we're on then we're gonna need to
have some sort of standards for the
character of the people that we seat in
high office I mean this is this is
getting to be beyond the pale and it has
been for twenty years but it seems to be
getting worse